hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the great work okay someone told me that
I needed to go back and get the cellar
go to the cellar wait what apparently I
can't go back so I guess I need to
progress forward all right I guess
that's just the way it is so some of you
said that that cellar that was locked
before it's where I need to be okay I've
done everything I possibly can my
attackers are convinced that I perished
my state has passed on to a private
investor risk few short exertions have
to live out my life here protecting my
shard but I need to find the ore for
shards
I am outnumbered and out overpowered and
my only hope is to stay a step ahead of
them I can find it first I may have a
chance not the Philosopher's stones and
should not be trifled with I've to stop
them before they claim countless lives
okay alright so I need to find the shard
and apparently it's in here I thought
because this was a cellar oh boy okay
that's where I need to go right so this
apparently is the cellar that I need to
go through I didn't know that I made a
loop-de-loop but apparently I did I'm
just scavenging for any sort of oil
before I go down into the darkness which
apparently I'm not gonna get okay so is
this just yeah I think this just comes
back to the hallway that I was at the
exit huh whoa more cellar okay probably
okay I shouldn't leave without the shard
so here we go into the darkness give me
give me give me what you get hello
nothing nothing okay carrying on
is that chase music is that mozzarella
chest have you got anything in you hey
come on let me crouch down jazz s let me
crouch down I can't get to it Jason
okay help there's a monster in here okay
nothing in there somebody I think this
is what they were talking about they
said they're gonna Bay I'll show you up
I see it I see it I see it I see it I
see it don't run don't run don't be nice
and calm that's income not gonna get me
it's not gonna get me cuz I'm hiding oh
hey don't know huh
it's it here place now I gotta get back
well that music sound like me ah sound
like me when I'm getting up in the
morning shut up Daniel Samuel Charles
whatever your name really is
[Music]
okay so he's in here I got to find the
comments said that there are four chests
in the cellar okay so I just gotta find
these four chests he's making a loop
he's making a loop there's another
chassis you it's gonna get lucky oh my
god
oh I'm so bummed I can't move these I
couldn't move them what the hell I
couldn't move them how was unfair oh
okay yeah do you think that Samuel maybe
Samuel jutted the through the shard
right into his chest maybe that's where
the shard is okay yeah this is the
blocked up area oh good it didn't take
me long to get back to where I was
okay so there's a fire burning but I
cannot I cannot move these for some
reason I thought oh then I might be able
to but apparently that's all wait what
oh that's just the door okay yeah okay
so I can't move those there's a I found
three chests I just need to find one
more and then I'm golden maybe I don't
know that's not a chest that's not a
nothing I can't move you okay no no no
no
no no let's go find the chest in this
corner um what am I looking for what am
i looking for what am I looking for
good thing the monsters not here
anything behind there no you know what
the Oh tits how did I ok it's like oil
consumption is accelerated this is not
fun it's not fair oil consumption is
that's opium ah I could use some right
about now oil consumption is definitely
accelerated ah ha
what the balls that's all for right the
guy in the comments said I only need to
find for what sir here what's in here
what's in here can't see can't see
running out of tinderboxes running out
everything oh there's more ok I just
found it ah ok so I need a Oh
ha ha ha oh I would have missed it
oh I wouldn't miss that what I wouldn't
miss that I'm so happy I have oil
I have oil and I'm not gonna waste it
this time I can get out of here now
let's check the far exit not the close
exit but the far exit I think this is
yeah this is the one
the address of the library wasn't far
but it started storming on my way I
constantly looked over my shoulder but
nothing seemed to be following me even
so I ran and ran all the way across
London never stopping even when the cold
rain and exhaustion made my legs scream
in pain maybe all the other people in
London PI thought you were kind of weird
doing that cuz I mean London big city
even back then
lots of people baby ok so apparently the
guy in the comment didn't understand
that I was right there
in the cellar already that was actually
the cellar ok so that was pretty
self-explanatory but thank you anyway
for you coming it's locked why am I not
surprised
is this an abandoned library hello baby
I think I saw the outline of you oh yeah
I definitely saw the outline of my
darling oh I loves long hallways it's
well that doorways by oil don't waste
the oil the oil is too precious to waste
precious
what do we got why don't we got man I
feel bad for anyone who plays through
this and doesn't get that oil at its
Nexus it was an association of personal
friends hartleb Drury okay who's talking
about the circle but as soon as one
looks any further from this than than
this from the center the lines of
communication between the branch and
cross it is a circle of a definable
center put on almost infinitely
expendable periphery so lots of people
involved with the circle so I'm I got my
volume turned up again so I hear all
those creeks and Crone's as if they were
right behind me I guess that's a good
thing about these professional Studio
Headphones
nice surround sound going on okay okay
okay
shut up
Oh hahaha thank you thank you
oil gods who have graced me with this
generous boon I appreciate it
now this well I just have to comment
right now this is how you do pacing in a
game No thank you no I'm not interested
in a moment but this this is exactly how
you do pacing in a game you get periods
of highs and periods of lows oh hello
hartleb died in 1662 in poverty close
friends reported he lost engine severed
contact 10th of March no funeral he'll
body buried hartleb never married and no
children his property went up for
auctions bought by a private investor ok
small books ok not necessary ok so most
of it yeah periods of highs and periods
of loads that's important you got to get
your you got to get the person
comfortable again no it's a problem with
the cry of fear campaign that I was
playing because it was constant up here
it stressed me out to no end you know I
couldn't just couldn't take it anymore
it was just too unbelievably high end
and it's just stressing you got to give
you you got to give the player time to
relax in order to recuperate so that you
can scare him again make him feel
comfortable and then take it all away
like I'm no game maker but I've learned
quite a bit playing these scary games
good more tinderboxes and I don't know
who made this but I wish that I could
get in contact with him because he is an
incredible incredible game maker Gabbar
has noted that one of the first
alchemist to theorize a possibility of
metal transmutation complete work
philosopher's stone catalysts great work
ah the great work led into gold actor
living homunculus attaining immortality
okay so I'm about reaching the end of
these hallways just one more door that
places ah someone has tried to break in
but uh the double boarding up okay let
me go find like a chair or some that I
can throw at that I need to find a chair
yeah it's dark where is it sure here we
go
maybe maybe one of these boxes would be
better probably they're a bit heftier
huh I seem to not be running as quickly
it's quite dark huh oops I missed oh
come on
dammit okay this isn't a solution
apparently okay I need to find a crowbar
or something yeah it's still dark sounds
very loud in my ear balls your balls is
it but roughly okay so where am I gonna
find moon crowbar maybe on the tops of
one of these shelves um ah boy who's
gonna be hard to find
okay don't hear anything I mean I've
said it a lot before but sound is
everything in a game sound is absolutely
paramount number-one priority if your
sound is not good and immersive it's not
gonna work out for you okay so this door
was locked there's nothing over here no
crowbars so well now what am I looking
for
what the hell are we fighting for okay
we're good
nice calm time to breathe so that I can
spend some quality time with you guys
and gals out in the audience thank you
by the way for watching hope you're
enjoying this I didn't find anything
else I am still walking quite slow this
store was locked these statues are here
I can't go back out Oh interesting
so the solution must be either in that
big library area which I'm gonna double
check real quick or the or the other
area which I'm also gonna check let's
just double-check everything make sure
that I did not miss a book on the
bookshelves nothing glowing purple
nothing at all nothing in the corner
everything checked in these drawers no
glows no glows no glow snow glows no
glows no glows no glows
no glows no glows nothing underneath
here no buttons no secret what's your
habits no secret anything that I see a
glow I did not what am I looking for I
do not see anything that I need to pull
on a bookshelf nothing that I need to
find no pulley books looking very
meticulously and every single shelf and
that's a negative I find nothing nothing
in here as well no pulley books no
pulley books okay so I am a lot of time
for this playthrough I will play till I
find it in the meantime and once I do
find it that's what I'll start recording
the next episode so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]